hey friends so I am currently working on
my review for the new pop and flow
system from flow toys and well I need a
couple weeks more on that but in the
meantime I did want to share with you
some of the awesome modes that these poy
are capable of
showing Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of Po spinning
and flow Arts to benefit your body and
brain
and today I am hopefully going to excite
both but before we dive in I just want
to give a quick shout out to the Friends
of the channel big thanks to dark monk
fire Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyrro Tera light toys spinballs
and Ultra poy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non- business
friend of the the channel Becca beonin
thank you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission cool so
if you are not familiar the pop and flow
system is a brand new modular system
from flow toys that is intended to allow
you to exchange LED Parts back and forth
between a number of different props and
make bigger props more portable so while
I'm working on my full review for the
system I thought it'd be cool to share
with you all some of the awesome modes
that you can get using these LED lights
and specifically with sets of poy so let
me set up my home studio and I will
share all that with you right
[Music]
now
oh
[Music]
I took my
heart in the weekend
is to
see and the
[Music]
we
w
cool so I hope you enjoyed all that if
you just cannot wait to get your hands
on a set of those pop and flow props
guess what I can get you a discount even
before the review comes out if you use
my special promo code drexfactor
3224 at checkout again that's drexfactor
32024 at checkout you can get 10% off
any one of the pop and flow props and of
course the cool connectors that make
them uh interchangeable with other props
so thanks much and uh look forward to
that review to come out in the next
couple
[Music]
weeks this video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on patreon
in particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now if you enjoy the videos
that I create and you'd like to support
me in making more of them there's an
easy way that you can do that head on
over to patreon that is patreon.com
drexfactor poy and sign up there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and even better than that you'll
be helping me out in my mission to bring
po spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world go check that out please and
thank you and if you'd like to check out
some of the product reviews that I have
already put up I will include a link to
a playlist of those down in the
description as well as up here on screen
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get out and flow today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon take care now
peace